portugal has started easing coronavirus
restrictions after a strict lockdown
that lasted more than
two months cafes museums shops
they can now welcome back guests under
strict hygienic guidelines
it's a comeback story for portugal which
back in january had one of the highest
coronavirus infection rates in the world
dw's young philip schultz went to the
capital lisbon to see how they did it
sitting in a cafe with friends still a
dream for millions possible again
in portugal nearly everyone spent the
last two months at home
this was forbidden but now shops primary
schools and cafes are open again
and people are delighted
it feels almost euphoric simply to be
able to sit here and watch people walk
past
i was in no way against the lockdown it
was very important
but i think we now all really need to be
able to enjoy life again
instead of just going to work and then
looking at our own four walls
what i missed the most was just looking
out at the water and drinking a beer
central lisbon looked like this for the
last couple of months
everything was closed the government
ordered most people to work from home
a radical lockdown in response to a
disaster
portugal had the world's highest corona
infection rates the
health system couldn't cope intensive
care units were overwhelmed
lockdown took daily infection numbers
from more than 12 000 at the start of
february
to fewer than 400 just nine weeks later
here outside lisbon's largest hospital
more than 40 ambulances had to wait in
line in front of the emergency ward
during the worst days of the pandemic
now only a few covet patients
have to be treated in the intensive care
unit and a field hospital
on the other side of the street was
closed weeks ago
some observers are already talking about
the miracle of portugal
balthazar nunes believes more in science
than miracles
an epidemiologist he's a member of the
portuguese government's corona advisory
group
he says one of the most unpopular
lockdown measures could have been
decisive
the numbers went down somewhat when we
first closed the shops and made remote
working compulsory
but it was only when we closed all the
schools
that the infection figures really
started to fall
he says despite the progress the danger
is not over and the pandemic will
continue to affect people's lives
even into the next year and the lockdown
was tough on the economy
pushing unemployment up by a third right
now though many portuguese people are
enjoying a moment in the sun
well despite half a year of restrictions
germany is still struggling to contain a
third wave of coronavirus infections
the high case load is fueling calls for
a tougher lockdown
but some german states are experimenting
with easing restrictions
a quick test and activities like sport
and cinema visits are allowed again
sarland in western germany has become
the first state to start loosening
restrictions
elsewhere scientists and some
politicians
are calling for stricter measures among
them chancellor merkel's conservative
party leader armin lachette
he's suggesting a temporary tightening
of restrictions
until enough people have been vaccinated
until that point in time and we are
talking about two or three weeks
we should make another effort to limit
public life
it's comments have been meshed with
criticism also from the opposition
for over a year the only thing policy
makers have been able to come up with is
shutting down public life
telling people to stay at home locking
down selling the same old policy with
new slogans
authorities are hoping to accelerate the
country's sluggish vaccine rollout
by allowing 35 000 general practitioners
across the country to start
administering the jobs this week
but in the capital berlin the
vaccination effort has experienced
a further snag with deliveries delayed
by what authorities called
technical problems two vaccination
centers had to close on tuesday
because they ran out of doses frustrated
by the situation
people in germany are calling for a
unified approach
the way the third wave is looking it
will be even more devastating than the
second
that's why i think there will be another
hard lockdown politicians somehow can't
seem to come up with anything else
they will just lock down until everyone
is vaccinated
we should first implement the measures
they've already agreed upon
they keep changing the rules then they
disagree then everyone does their own
thing
it's hard to understand
if our leaders manage to stop arguing
then there will be a hard lockdown
there's probably no other way to solve
it
but the country's federal political
system is getting in the way
ultimately it's the states that decide
on and implement the measures
for now chancellor angela merkel is not
intervening
but she has warned that if the situation
demands it
she could try to take matters into her
own hands
ndw political correspondent thomas
sparrow joins us now from berlin
thomas icu staff in germany are warning
that there are not too many beds left
how hard is this third wave hitting the
country
it is certainly hitting the country very
hard in particular because of the more
prevalent coronavirus
variant which has been described as more
contagious and contagious also for
longan which has led sara to an increase
in the number of coronavirus cases here
in germany and also by the way
to a growing debate about what path the
country
should take in the next few weeks and in
the next few months
this is by the way a debate on a
situation that is not only happening
here in germany also in other european
countries and in many of germany's
neighboring countries as well which only
makes a situation here in this
country more and more difficult and more
and more challenging there are
a few caveats a few good news as part of
all this situation
one of them being that the number of
deaths have been going down and also
a positive development when you look at
the infections among germany's
older population but all in all the
situation is certainly
very difficult when it comes to this
third wave of the coronavirus pandemic
and it's taking place uh
the pandemic we have to say against the
backdrop also of uh federal elections
that are coming up later this year tell
us um
you know in terms of management of the
pandemic how politicized has it
therefore
become thomas and how how is that
potentially
impacting the prospect of further
lockdown measures
well it has always been political right
from the start but it is uh
it is uh important to stress now that
it's becoming more and more political
more and more
intense as germany gets closer to that
all-important federal election in
september which will decide
the successor to angela merkel in the
german
chancellery and obviously all parties
involved
all candidates involved are trying to
position themselves appropriately when
it comes to
deciding what path germany should face
in the next few weeks and in particular
sarah to decide a very important dilemma
that politicians are facing
whether the country should carefully
cautiously
open up or whether further and stricter
restrictions should be in place to try
and deal
with this third wave of the pandemic
thomas sparrow in berlin thank you
u.s president joe biden says that all
adults in the united states will be
eligible to get a coronavirus vaccine by
april 19th two weeks earlier than the
previous government deadline
he warned however that cases are still
going up for the moment urging people to
get vaccinated as soon as possible
in new york state everyone older than 16
can already get a shot
relief for three teenagers who know how
dangerous
cloven 19 is hannah's whole family got
sick with the virus last year
paul loves playing for his wheelchair
high school basketball team
but going back to school threatens his
health
and brianna has a rare condition sickle
cell anemia
vaccination is a matter of life or death
for her
i feel like at the end of the day as
long as you have some sort of protection
against the deadly virus it's all worth
it in the end
downtown new york city it's not bustling
not yet at least
but an estimated one in three new
yorkers has now been
vaccinated which means there's a feeling
of re-awakening
this spring i think there's a new
profound sense of optimism in the past
month in new york for sure
my family is from germany so they're
still in a lockdown and like my parents
didn't even get the shot yet so it feels
kind of weird that i already got it here
at a church near washington now being
used to vaccinate people applause for
the u.s president
joe biden came here to tout the hundreds
of millions of doses
set aside for americans but carl you
probably came and wanted a shot and i'm
biting's holding you up here
the u.s has already given a first dose
to more than 150 million people
but tens of millions more are still
waiting by no later than april 19th
in every part of this country every
adult
over the age of 18 18 or older will be
eligible to be vaccinated
not everywhere in the u.s is advancing
so rapidly
in sunny california adults over 50 only
became eligible
at the start of the month but here too
the effects of the vaccination program
are visible with los
angeles reopening and crowds gathering
at this flower festival near san diego
it's not the end of the pandemic not yet
but much of the world can only dream of
pleasures like this
amnesty international's annual report
says that covet 19 has further amplified
massive global inequalities and it
accuses many world leaders
of using the pandemic to crack down on
human rights
now the report singles out three groups
that have been disproportionately
affected
first women they have suffered an
increase in domestic violence born the
brunt of homeschooling and in many cases
lost their income because they had
informal jobs that they couldn't do
under lockdown
second healthcare workers around the
globe
they have suffered more fatalities than
any other group
chronic underinvestment in health
systems means many hospitals are
understaffed
and their workers are not sufficiently
protected against the virus
finally the third group the pandemic
also worsening the already precarious
situation of refugees and
migrants lockdowns and border closures
have left some trapped in squalid camps
without access to vital supplies
let's go now to johannesburg and speak
with netsanet bellai he
is a research and advocacy director at
amnesty international welcome to the
program
and thank you so much for joining us
this report saying
the world's most vulnerable marginalized
people have borne the brunt of the
pandemic
how bad is the situation
it's as bad as it gets we believe that
those who were
who gave us the most were were protected
the least and those who were
marginalized were really exposed the
most and you cited some of the examples
let's take a look at the situation of
refugees and migrants
in far too many countries the precarious
situation in which
refugees and migrants were was even
expanded by by this pandemic take a look
at some
the example from u.s border with mexico
where over half a million refugees and
migrants were expelled from the
country including the 30 000
unaccompanied children
let's go to uganda a home for 1.4
million refugees
has closed its borders stranding over 10
000 refugees along the border with drc
and and and the other aspect is the
impact on informal
workers those working in the gig economy
our cleaners our
our seasonal workers who are left
without any income
or social protections to do that and
mind you most of these
are also women who who take care of
families
and they were left without any social
protection in that regard
and speaking of women and girls 2020
also showed us
a marked increase in domestic prevalence
um as a result of lockdowns following
the lockdowns because of lack of
adequate protections by governments i
mean in nigeria
so oh sorry i just wanted to ask you i
mean
what you're describing here you're
painting this this picture of this
huge human impact um you know another
wrinkle in
in in this report um that amnesty has
documented is the fact that governments
using the coronavirus to stifle dissent
in their countries walk us through that
aspect of this story who are the biggest
offenders there
the many in the least sarah and i it's
as if a violent trade of leader has
emerged that weaponized coffee to
to launch fresh assaults on human rights
let's take example from hungary
which introduced a new law criminalizing
any false dissemination of
information about kovid to present terms
to five years
zimbabwe introduces a similar law but
only the sentence is
20 years under five years
many countries have have actually
resorted to
excessive and brutal police force to
enforce kobe regulations
zimbabwe over 116 000 people
were detained for violating kobe
regulations
others like china and india have
actually used the kovid
as a distraction to perpetuate an
escalated clampdown on descent
and and minorities india is one of those
who have
went on a rampage to crack down on civil
society activists
including using anti-terrorism laws and
etc
in china the situation with yogurts is
further escalated
following the crisis and many being
persecuted as has
been widely reported so these are the
kind of
patterns that emerge in far too many
countries where governments have used
as a pretext and we thank you so much
for joining us to tell us a little bit
more about that nissanet bellai
research and advocacy director at
amnesty international
as your organization releases its annual
report
thank you for joining us to share the
findings
thank well you has reported more than
4 000 new daily deaths from covet 19 for
the first time
the nation's pandemic death toll is now
approaching 340 000
second only to the united states experts
say that a local variant of the virus
has caused the latest surge which has
pushed the health care system
into a breaking point right-wing
president jair bolsonaro
has also opposed lockdown measures as
damaging to the economy
but many of brazil's poorest citizens
are crying out for
help they say the government's pandemic
response has failed them
and without more aid many risk going
hungry
these protesters are sending a message
to their government
brazil is hungry here in sao paulo's
largest
favela parisopoulos residents say
emergency aid doesn't go
far enough my fear is that my daughters
will go hungry
one of them's still under 18. there's
also my granddaughter
and i think to myself will they go
hungry
up until december the brazilian
government provided those in need with
around 90 euros per month in aid
community centres like this one have
been offering free meals
but donations have dropped president
jair bolsonaro's administration
is once again offering help but a more
modest amount
a community movement known as g10 is
demanding more
well cinematic since the emergency aid
of 23 euros is enough to buy a domestic
gas cylinder
5 kilograms of rice and 1 kilogram of
beans
a family can't survive a month on that
it's shameful brazil is a rich country
and
letting its population go hungry and the
pandemic is still
out of control brazil is a country in
crisis
and there's not much light on the
horizon
some other developments now in the
coronavirus pandemic in france the
number of patients in intensive care
is at its highest in almost a year
france is now
in a month-long lockdown india has hit
another new
record number of daily cases new delhi
mumbai and dozens of other cities are
imposing curfews to try and slow the
soaring infections
and a top official at the european
medicines agency says there
is a link between the astrazeneca
vaccine and rare blood clots
the agency is expected to release a new
assessment of the drug
this week